un petit brin de muguet social pour ce
1er mai le rassemblement de ce matin à
dijon et à l'initiative de trois
syndicats solidaires fsu et la cgt les
syndicats sont présents les travailleurs
également mais aussi des étudiants cette
semaine est chargée socialement le
conflit des cheminots va entamer son
septième épisode
air france se dirige vers ses 12e et 13e
journées de grève
la contestation est dans l'air du temps
on sent bien si vous voulez que la
moitié de la population s'interroge au
minimum se dit que là il ya vraiment un
enjeu et il faut vraiment qu'on s'y
mette et et voilà on en jeu en service
public en conditions de travail en
conditions de vie et ça concerne tout à
chacun y compris on va dire les usagers
des transports en commun qu'ils y certes
c'est vrai que ça me gêne que ça
m'embête c'est tout ça ok mais pour
autant je suis concerné on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de comment dire ça de strates
sociales et de métier qui finalement
sont mécontents de la politique actuelle
la politique actuelle donc c'est bien
qu'elle se rassemble
ensemble aujourd'hui que ce soit les
travailleurs ce soit les étudiants et
tous les mécontents de la politique de
nice matin
cette journée s'inscrit dans une action
sociale mais se veut aussi être un
moment de rassemblement pour toute la
société
on se rend compte que le gouvernement et
le président de la république mène des
maines des députés des réformes qui
atteinte au pouvoir d'achat par exemple
des retraités aux droits collectifs des
salariés mais également à l'ensemble des
services publics le 1er mai est un jour
qui est aussi célébrée à travers 140
pays dans le monde plusieurs prises de
parole avant la manifestation ont permis
d'évoquer les zones de conflit actuel
est appelé à la paix